This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. That is the sound of exactly 2008 trimmers pounding away in perfect synchronicity during the opening ceremony of the 2008 Beijing Summer Olympics. the opening ceremony of the 2008 Beijing Summer Olympics. The entire stadium pitched into darkness as the traditional Chinese faux-drammed globe from within. It was just the start of a ceremony widely regarded as the most elaborate in the Olympic history, and it was all designed and executed perfectly. But behind the scenes there was one small hitch in the coverage of the event
这里是“99%无形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。那是2008年北京夏季奥运会开幕式上，整整2008台击缶器以完美同步的节奏轰鸣的声音。体育场陷入一片黑暗，一个传统的中国假鼓地球从内部升起。这仅仅是一场被广泛认为是对奥运历史上最精心制作的仪式的开始，而且它的设计和执行都堪称完美。但在幕后，这次活动的转播却出现了一个小插曲
that went mostly unreported. That's producer Daniel Seymour. During the parade of nations, Greece has the birthplace of the Olympics and at first that's a longstanding tradition. But then the rest of the teams came out according to the number of strokes in the Chinese characters that comprise their name. The country of Jamaica, for example, was followed by Belgium. Then came Bonoatu, which in turn was followed by Israel.
这个插曲基本上没有被报道过。那是制作人丹尼尔·西摩。在运动员入场式期间，希腊作为奥运会的发源地首先出场，起初这是一个悠久的传统。但随后其余的代表团则是根据其名称构成的汉字笔画数出场的。例如，牙买加紧随比利时之后。然后是瓦努阿图，接着是以色列。
The US team walked out somewhere in the middle. My home country of Australia was right at the back, 200 and second in line. Ultimately, the sequence of nations was just a small detail. In a 4 hour, $300 million ceremony, it should not have been the hard part. But for the Western networks covering the games, the parade proved a little tricky. Because it seems to us perfectly natural that the teams march in an alphabetical order. That's Judith Flanders, author of a place for everything, a book about the order of the Latin alphabet.
美国代表团排在中间的某个地方。我的祖国澳大利亚则排在最后，位列第202位。归根结底，国家入场顺序只是一个小细节。在长达4小时、耗资3亿美元的仪式中，这本不该是难点。但对于转播奥运会的西方电视台来说，这个入场式却有点棘手。因为在我们看来，各代表团按字母顺序入场是极其自然的。这是朱迪丝·弗兰德斯的话，她是《万物皆有其位》（一本关于拉丁字母顺序的书）的作者。
So it made all of the Western Network scramble because they simply didn't know when their own teams were going to come in and when they could go to commercial breaks. In the confusion of trying to figure out which countries came after which breaks, NBC later posted the footage to their website in the wrong order. This in turn sparked a short-lived message board conspiracy theory that the networks had deliberately changed up the order of nations in order to increase site traffic.
因此，这让所有的西方电视台都乱作一团，因为他们根本不知道自己的代表团什么时候会出场，什么时候可以进入商业广告。由于搞不清哪个国家在哪个广告时段之后出场，NBC后来在其网站上以错误的顺序发布了这段视频。这反过来又引发了一个短暂存在的留言板阴谋论，即各大电视台故意调换了国家的入场顺序，以增加网站流量。
You know, despite the fact that probably if you had asked the organizers doing the Olympic coverage, they would have known that Chinese does not use an alphabet, but it didn't quite penetrate. So in that way you see how deeply embedded the alphabet is in our psyches. For much of the Western world, alphabetical order is the default. It's often the one we try first, or the one we use as a last resort when all other ordering methods fail. It's boring, but it works, and it's so ingrained that it's hard to imagine not using it.
你知道，尽管事实上，如果你去问负责奥运报道的组织者，他们会知道中文并不使用字母表，但这并没有完全被他们消化。所以从某种程度上，你可以看到字母表在我们的脑海中根深蒂固到了什么程度。对于西方世界的大多数人来说，字母顺序是默认选项。它通常是我们首先尝试的排序方式，或者当所有其他排序方法都失效时，我们作为最后手段使用的排序方式。它很无聊，但它确实管用，而且它已经深入人心，以至于很难想象不用它的生活。
Except at one point, we didn't. Alphabetical order, as a way to organize information, is a pretty recent development, and its adoption is part of a radical shift in the way human beings learn, organize their thoughts, and even see their place in the way human beings learn, organize their thoughts, and even see their place in the world. But before you can order anything alphabetically, you need an alphabet. The alphabet is a concept of applying symbols to sounds and saying this stands for this and this only.
除了在某个时期，我们确实没有用过。字母顺序作为一种组织信息的方式，是一个相当近期的发展，而它的采纳是人类学习、组织思想甚至看待自己在世界上的地位的方式发生根本性转变的一部分。但在你能按字母顺序排列任何东西之前，你需要一个字母表。字母表是一个将符号应用于声音的概念，即这个符号代表这个声音，且仅代表这个声音。
That's Timothy Donaldson, a type designer and lecturer at Formathe University in England and author of the book Shapes for Sounds. And Donaldson says that the process of assigning sounds to symbols took a long time, because at first all we had were pictograms, images that represented whole objects or concepts, like in very early Sumerian writing. So if you wanted to represent the idea of a fish, you drew a fish. But what the problem it brings with it is you need a massive amount of symbols. You need thousands of symbols to represent every single thing.
这是蒂姆·唐纳森，英国福马泰大学的字体设计师兼讲师，也是《声音的形状》一书的作者。唐纳森说，将声音分配给符号的过程花很长时间才完成，因为起初我们只有象形图，即代表整个物体或概念的图像，就像非常早期的苏美尔文字那样。所以如果你想表达“鱼”这个概念，你就画一条鱼。但这带来的问题是，你需要大量的符号。你需要数千个符号来代表每一个单一的事物。
So the system is unwieldy. Eventually these pictograms changed and became more abstract, and by 2800 BCE, certain marks began to represent syllables. But not individual consonants or vowels, so there might be a symbol for an entire syllable, like ga, but nothing yet for its component ga and ga sounds individually, meaning each syllable in a language needed a sign. And they could get by with about 700 symbols. We call our syllabary.
因此这个系统非常笨拙。最终这些象形图发生了变化，变得更加抽象，到公元前2800年，某些符号开始代表音节。但还不是单独的辅音或元音，因此可能会有一个符号代表整个音节，比如“ga”，但还没有单独针对它的“g”和“a”音的成分，这意味着语言中的每个音节都需要一个符号。我们把这称为音节文字，当时我们可以用大约700个符号应付过去。
But a syllabary still isn't an alphabet. But at some point, some clever, early, Semitic speaking, someone saw that the Egyptians were writing stuff down and said, hey, we can do that for my language. That's Peter Daniels, an independent scholar specializing in ancient writing systems. Daniels says that the Egyptians were using their uncomplicated non-syllabic system of symbols. When our hypothetical early Semitic someone decided to take that Egyptian system and simplify it.
但音节文字仍然不是字母表。但在某个时候，某个聪明的、早期的闪米特语使用者看到埃及人在写东西，就说，嘿，我们可以为我的语言做这件事。这是彼得·丹尼尔斯，一位专门研究古代书写系统的独立学者。丹尼尔斯说，当我们的这个假设中的早期闪米特人决定采用埃及系统并对其进行简化时，埃及人正在使用他们那种简单的、非音节的符号系统。
Because this clever inventor had the brilliant idea to use just one consonant per letter, still no vowels, but with those consonants they could write anything that needed to be written. Developing what some scholars considered to be the first true alphabet, and with it, the first alphabetical order. In that first ever alphabetical order, would be instantly recognizable. It's the same basic order that the Latin alphabet uses today. In the 1940s, archaeologists found a set of small tablets
因为这位聪明的发明家有一个绝妙的主意，即每个字母只使用一个辅音，仍然没有元音，但有了这些辅音，他们就可以写出任何需要写的东西。这就发展成了某些学者认为的最早的真正的字母表，随之而来的，是最初的字母顺序。那个史上最早的字母顺序，将会具有极高的辨识度。它与今天拉丁字母使用的基本顺序相同。20世纪40年代，考古学家在现今叙利亚的古城乌加里特发现了一组小泥板，
with some 3,200-year-old lettering in the ancient city of Ugarit in present-day Syria. With nothing on them, but the 30 letters of the Ugaritic alphabet, and they were all written in the familiar order that became ABCDEF, etc. Everything from A to T. T was the last letter in that particular alphabetical order. The exact shapes of the ugaritic letters would go through a lot of changes as they got adapted. Early on by the Phoenicians, then the Greeks, and later the Romans. But the basic order was there from the beginning.
上面有一些3200年前的字母。上面除了乌加里特字母表的30个字母外别无他物，而且它们都是以我们熟悉的顺序书写的，也就是变成A、B、C、D、E等。从A到T应有尽有。T是那个特定字母顺序中的最后一个字母。乌加里特字母的具体形状在被改编的过程中经历了很多变化。早期由腓尼基人，然后是希腊人，后来是罗马人。但基本的顺序从一开始就存在了。
But that raises a fundamental question. Why that order? Why ABC and not NQD or RGL? And the answer is, well, we don't know. It was a long time ago. Okay, fair. There's no particular reason we just learn the alphabet in the order it's in. There was, however, at least one competing alphabetical order from around that same time,
但这引发了一个根本性的问题。为什么是这个顺序？为什么是ABC而不是NQD或RGL？答案是，好吧，我们不知道。那是很久以前的事了。好吧，这倒也合理。并没有什么特别的原因，我们只是按字母原有的顺序学习它。然而，在大约同一时期，至少存在着另一个相互竞争的字母顺序，
found into southern Arabian peninsula in present-day Yemen and Oman. So similar alphabet, but different sequence. It went H, L, a strange looking letter, I can't pronounce or recognize M, R, etc. But outside of a few small areas, this other order never caught on. And for the usual reason. The one that went out was the one that was used by the people that went out and conquered other people. That just happens.
在现今也门和阿曼所在的阿拉伯半岛南部被发现。所以字母相似，但顺序不同。它是以H、L开头，还有一个我发不出音也认不出来的长相奇怪的字母，然后是M、R等等。但除了少数几个小地区之外，这种其他的顺序从未流行开来。原因也很常规。最终胜出的那个顺序，是被那些四处征战并征服其他民族的人所使用的顺序。事情往往就是这样。
The South Arabian people were more limited in their conquering. The Romans, on the other hand, love conquering. And as they conquered, they spread their alphabetical order around. Although not before making some last-minute tweaks, take the final two letters, Y and Z. The Romans in Houston. Tim Donaldson says that the ancient Greek equivalents of Y and Z had previously been disfersed in the middle of the Greek alphabet.
南阿拉伯人的征服活动较为局限。另一方面，罗马人则酷爱征服。随着他们的征服，他们将自己的字母顺序传播开来。尽管在传播之前做了一些最后的微调，比如最后两个字母Y和Z。提姆·唐纳森说，罗马人此前将古希腊语中对应的Y和Z分散在希腊字母表的中间。
But then the Romans chucked them out. Yeah, yeah, it was literally how it happened. And then eventually they found that they were useful so they got brought back into the fold. That's where they're at the end. The letter K was luckier. It was also kicked out at some point, but then brought back in at the same spot as before. They also tried to introduce three new Roman letters and it just didn't work.
但后来罗马人把它们给扔掉了。是的，是的，事情字面意思就是这样的。然后最终他们发现这些字母挺有用，于是它们又被重新请回阵营中。这就是它们出现在末尾的原因。字母K则更幸运一些。它在某个时候也被踢了出去，但后来又在之前相同的位置被请了回来。他们还试图引入三个新的罗马字母，但就是行不通。
Well, we're the ones. One was called diagama and one looks, I can't remember the name of the other two, even though I wrote a book about it. So for the most part, the alphabets order has proved remarkably stable. But despite its endurance, for most of its history, alphabetical order wasn't actually used to order much of anything. Alphabetical order was not all that important for anything beyond learning the alphabet. In societies like Ancient Rome and early medieval Europe, writing implements were still rare. So what mattered most was organizing knowledge
好吧，我们就是这样。其中一个叫“digamma”，还有一个看起来，我记不清另外两个的名字了，尽管我为此写过本书。所以大部分情况下，字母表的顺序被证明是非常稳定的。但尽管它历经岁月，在其历史的大部分时间里，字母顺序实际上并没有被用来对任何东西进行排序。除了学习字母表本身之外，字母顺序其实并没有那么重要。在像古罗马和欧洲中世纪早期这样的社会中，书写工具仍然很稀缺。所以最重要的是以某种方式组织知识，
in a way that helped you to memorize it. And that was usually much easier to do in the order you naturally came across the information. So you might memorize the names of kings in chronological order, following who began who, or all the towns along the coastline from east to west. And Judith Flander says that this means in most cases, alphabetical order would have been kind of useless.
这种方式能帮助你记住它们。而这通常用你自然接触到这些信息的顺序来做要容易得多。因此，你可能会按照时间顺序记住国王的名字，根据谁接着谁继位，或者记住沿着海岸线从东到西的所有城镇。朱迪丝·弗兰德斯说，这意味着在大多数情况下，字母顺序其实没什么用。
And the way I've begun to think of it is to say to people, okay put the days the week enough, medical order. Let's see. Friday, Monday, and there's always a very long pause. Thursday, Tuesday. Because we don't think of them that way. We started Monday. Saturday, Sunday, Wednesday. Jesus. So when it came to sorting and organizing actual information, for thousands of years, people used almost any other method. They organized things by size, by geography, by chronology, just not alphabetically. But these early ordering methods also reflected the way people thought about the world, and one important way that they thought about it was hierarchically.
我开始思考这个问题的方式是，对人们说：“好吧，把一周的日子按医学（译注：应为字母，原文误读）顺序排一下。让我们看看。星期五，星期一……”然后总会有很长的停顿，“星期四，星期二……”因为我们不是那样想它们的。我们从星期一开始。“星期六，星期天，星期三……天哪。”因此，在对实际信息进行分类和整理时，几千年来，人们几乎使用任何其他方法。他们按大小、按地理、按年代来组织事物，就是不按字母顺序。但这些早期的排序方法也反映了人们对世界的看法，他们看待世界的一个重要方式就是按等级层次。
In the Middle Ages, for example, William the Conqueror's Doomsday book, which was a survey of all his subjects' property assets, was divided into sections that started with the nobles and ended with the peasants. So you moved down not alphabetically, but through more or less who had more money and who had more power. Church documents also tended to reflect this hierarchical view. Where the church fathers come first and then other theological writers, then other less important writers, and finally, Wismer, pagan writers. They weren't even Christian, and they trail in the end
例如，在中世纪，征服者威廉的《末日审判书》（这是一份对他所有臣民的财产资产进行调查的文书）被划分为几个部分，从贵族开始，到农民结束。所以你往下走，不是按字母顺序，而是或多或少根据谁更有钱、谁更有权力。教会文件也往往反映这种等级森严的观点。其中教会之父排在最前面，然后是其他神学作家，接着是不那么重要的作家，最后是“Wismer”（译注：应指异教徒作家pagan writers，此处语音转写有误），即异教徒作家。他们甚至都不是基督徒，最后才被提及，
because they're not important. But nowhere was this hierarchical world that you're more apparent than an encyclopedias. These books were primarily religious documents written by adjabishops and monks who were attempting to create what they called a mirror of the world. Starting with God, the angels, and the saints at the front,
因为他们不重要。但这种等级森严的世界观在百科全书中最具表现力。这些书主要是由大主教和修士撰写的宗教文献，他们试图创造他们所谓的“世界的镜子”。前面从上帝、天使和圣徒开始，
and plants and inanimate objects at the very back. Humans were usually somewhere in the middle. Theological books might have glossaries of difficult terms at the back, but these would be organized in the order they appear in the book, not alphabetically. Because in a world where knowledge was considered complete and holistic, the point was not to look up only the facts you needed, but to read the book from beginning to end. You might occasionally come across a merchant's invoice or one small part of a dictionary organized alphabetically, but even as late as the Middle Ages, alphabetical order was still so rare that
而植物和无生命物体则排在最后面。人类通常排在中间的某个地方。神学书籍的背面可能有难懂词汇的词汇表，但这些词汇会按照它们在书中出现的顺序排列，而不是按字母顺序。因为在一个被认为知识是完整且整体的世界里，重点不是查找你需要的唯一事实，而是从头到尾阅读这本书。你可能偶尔会遇到按字母顺序排列的商人发票或字典的一小部分，但即使到了中世纪晚期，字母顺序依然非常罕见，以至于
anytime someone used it in a book, they would have to explain it. So you'd get this kind of primer from the author at the beginning, where he might say, if the topic you're interested in starts with Z, try looking towards the end. And it's perfectly clear. He thinks he has invented it. And then each time another person uses it. They too explain it over and over. Slowly though, little by little, alphabetical order would start to catch on. We can't say why exactly, but Judith Flann is points to one potential reason, at least for those who knew their ABCs. Every other sorting order, you need to know a little bit about the subject to help you find things.
每当有人在书中将其用上时，他们都必须进行解释。所以你会从作者那里得到这种开篇的入门说明，他可能会说：“如果你感兴趣的主题以Z开头，试着往后翻。”而且这非常清楚。他认为这是他自己发明的。然后每当另一个人使用它时，他们也同样一遍又一遍地解释。不过，慢慢地，一点一点地，字母顺序开始流行起来。我们说不出具体原因，但朱迪丝·弗兰德斯指出了一个潜在原因，至少对那些识字的人来说是这样：在所有其他的排序顺序中，你需要对主题有一些了解才能帮助你找到东西。
Alpha-bethical order is the only sorting order that we have where you do not need to have any preliminary knowledge. In this proved useful, in a world where increasingly, there was just too much to remember. In the 11th and 12th centuries, with the arrival of paper technology from China, writing something down started to become a lot cheaper and more attractive than trying to memorize it. For theology students at European universities, this helped facilitate a new form of learning, one in which arguments and counter
字母顺序是我们拥有的唯一不需要任何预备知识的排序顺序。事实证明，这在信息越来越多、让人根本记不过来的世界里非常有用。在11和12世纪，随着来自中国的造纸技术的传入，把事情写下来变得比试图死记硬背要便宜得多，也更有吸引力。对于欧洲大学的神学学生来说，这有助于促进一种新的学习形式，在这种形式中，论点和反论点都需要有书面证据的支持，但这也意味着现在你必须知道去哪里找所有这些来源，以便你能正确引用它们。因此，学者们开始开发创新的方式来搜索信息、编索引、标页码、以及将一物与他物交叉引用的方法。这就带来了所有这些能帮助我们定位事物的事物的发展，或者正如我所称的——“查资料”。我们变成了一个“查资料”的世界。而“查资料”最顺手的方法之一，就是直接按名字查。
arguments were expected to be backed up by written evidence, but it also meant that now you have to know where to find all those sources so you could cite them correctly. So scholars began developing innovative ways to search for information, indexing, pagination, methods for cross referencing one thing with another. And this brings with it the development of all of these things that help us locate things or, as I call it, look stuff up. We become a look stuff up world. And one of the handiest ways to look stuff up was simply by name.
通过字母顺序，你不需要成为某个领域的专家就知道在哪里可以找到东西。最顺手的方法之一，就是直接按名字。流动的法语（译注：此处原文疑为法语短语或地名误听，语境指一种便携手册）是一本完整的综合指南，但现在他们随身带着一本小册子，里面提供了解圣经不同主题的谈话要点，正好赶上下一次布道使用。所以这些东西实际上就是小抄，为了让它们更易于使用，它们被排成了字母顺序。推动字母顺序兴起的另一个重要因素是15世纪印刷术的到来。既然书籍很容易复制，出版商们意识到他们可以通过出售单一书名的多个副本来赚大钱，而畅销书往往是参考书。起初，许多这些参考书仍然努力成为
With Alvedic order, you didn't need to be an expert in a field to know where to find something. the handiest ways to look stuff up was simply my name. Traveling French is a complete comprehension, but now they would have a small booklet with them which would provide talking points on different subjects from the Bible just in time for the next sermon. So what these were is effectively, they were cheat sheets, and to make them easier to use they were put in alphabetical order. Another big factor in the rise of alphabetical order was the arrival in the 15th century of the printing press. Now that books were easy to copy, publishers realized they could make big money selling multiple copies of a single title, and the best sellers often turned out to be reference books. At first, many of these reference books still strive to be
世界的镜子，按等级森严的结构组织。但随着像狄德罗这样的启蒙运动百科全书派编纂者将越来越多的词条和越来越多的贡献者纳入其中，在不打乱其他所有内容的情况下添加新词条的最简单方法，就是按字母顺序进行组织。因此，他们赞许伟大的等级方案，但他们不使用它。相反，他们说他们将使用字母顺序，因为它是预先约定、更加便利且更容易的。
mirrors of the world, organized hierarchically. But as enlightenment and cyclopetus, like Dittarrow, incorporated more and more entries for more and more contributors, the easiest way to add a new entry without shuffling everything else around was just to organize it alphabetically. And so they cite the great hierarchy schemes, but they don't use it. And instead they say they're going to use alphabetical order because it is pre-commoded, a pre-facil, more convenient and easier.
但正当学者们忙于将天使们按字母顺序排列时，统治阶层的其他成员却对这种划分世界的新方法感到很不高兴。为了理解其中的原因，弗兰德斯提到了16世纪一部献给法国国王的目录学著作。编纂者在序言中为将其按字母顺序排列而道歉。因为他说，这可能意味着仆人排在主人前面，孩子排在父母前面。它颠覆了等级制度，
But even as scholars were busy alphabetizing the angels, other members of the establishment weren't happy about this new method of dividing up the world. To understand why, Flanders points to a 16th century bibliography dedicated to the King of France. And the compiler apologizes in his preface for putting it in alphabetical order. Because he says this might mean servants come before masters and children before their parents. It upends hierarchy, and
而且这是危险的。”更糟糕的是，这是一种组织知识的方式，它允许任何识字的人选择自己想学的东西。如果没有一个更高级的秩序，知识就不再是一套由博学的权威人士传下来的固定观念。相反，由个人来决定什么东西值得去发现，什么东西可以被忽略。所以，如果你有知识的把关人，那些把关人就会认为我们很快就要失业了。这种情绪不仅局限于1500年代的一群保皇派反动分子。字母顺序最大的死敌大概是19世纪初的英国诗人
it is dangerous." Even worse, this was a way of organizing knowledge that allowed any literate person to choose what to learn. Without a better order, knowledge was no longer a fixed set of ideas to be handed down by learned authorities. Instead, it was up to the individual to decide what was worth discovering and what could be ignored. So if you've got gatekeepers to knowledge, those gatekeepers are going to think we're going to be out of work soon. And this feeling wasn't just restricted to a bunch of royal reactionaries in the 1500s. Alphabetical order's biggest hater was probably the early 19th century English poet,
萨缪尔·泰勒·柯勒律治。柯勒律治！他简直对它深恶痛绝！柯勒律治为《大英百科全书》在地狱里留了个特殊的位置，当然，这部百科全书是按字母顺序排列的。作为一名神学家兼诗人，他信仰伟大的知识等级制，他认为英国最卓越的参考书应该反映这一点。他说，是的，它反映了世界。但一旦它处于这种随意的、他认为
Samuel Taylor Colrich. Colrich! He just despised it! Colrich saved a special place in hell for the encyclopedia Britannica, which was, of course, organized alphabetically. As a theologian, as well as a poet, he believed in the great hierarchy of knowledge, and he thought Britain's pre-eminent reference book should reflect that. And he said, yes, it reflects the world. But once it's in this arbitrary and he thought
荒谬的顺序中——比如“苹果”因为以A开头所以排在第一位——你得到的其实是一个碎在地上的镜子，每一块碎片都反映了世界的一小部分，但整体上却毫无意义。我必须承认，就文学批评而言，这其实挺优美的。我的意思是，他是个诗人。但他也是个势利小人。那种字母顺序一直在瓦解的“Substack式”写作知识分子（译注：原文为sub-stack writing intellectual，此处带讽刺意味）。所以不管怎么说，他的反对意见让他显得有点与时代脱节。他甚至在小说中被恶搞为“化学、植物学、地质学、天文学、数学、形而上学、气象学、解剖学、生理学、电学、音乐、绘画、目录学、至关重要的哲学家”。换句话说，他是个令人讨厌的万事通。
ridiculous order Aka Apple comes first just because it starts with A. What you've got is a broken mirror on the ground, each reflecting a little bit of the world but making no overall sense. Which I'll admit, as far as literary criticism goes, is kind of beautiful. I mean, he was a poet. But he was also a snob. The kind of sub-stack writing intellectual that alphabetical order had been undermining all along. So if anything, his objections made him seem a little out of touch. He was even parodied and novels as quote, the chemical botanical, geological, astronomical, mathematical, metaphysical, meteorological, anatomical, physiological, galvanistical, musical, pictorial, bibliographical, crucial, philosopher. In other words, he was an insufferable note all.
事实是，当像柯勒律治这样的人在大喊大叫让字母顺序从他们的草坪上滚开时，战斗其实早就已经结束了。在某个无人注意的时刻，既不需要伟大的拥护者去推动它，也不需要轰轰烈烈的运动去宣传它，字母顺序已经胜利了。而其他的可能性则渐渐淡去了。人们渐渐忽视了这样一个事实：其实还存在着其他的可能性。今天，根据名称组织信息已经变得如此司空见惯，以至于它常常被忽视，
The truth is, by the time guys like Coleridge were shouting at alphabetical order to get off their lawn, the battle was already over. At some point, when no one was looking, without needing a great champion to advance it or campaign to promote it, alphabetical order had won. And other possibilities sort of faded. People lost sight of the fact that there are other possibilities. Today organizing information according to its name has become so commonplace that it often just goes unnoticed,
但它仍然带有自身的偏见。去问问任何一个名字以字母表末尾字母开头的人就知道了。学术经济学家如果名字在字母表靠前的位置，更有可能被引用、在名牌大学获得工作，甚至赢得诺贝尔奖。政治候选人如果名字在字母表靠前而不是靠后，更有可能获胜。甚至有一种叫做“字母疲劳”的现象，即字典或百科全书团队在处理字母时，会随着进展变得越来越不严谨。《大英百科全书》的第一版按字母排序的版次有三卷，每一卷大致
but it still commens with its own biases. Just ask anyone whose name starts with a letter at the end of the alphabet. Academic economists are more likely to be cited, get jobs at prestigious universities, and even win Nobel prizes if their names are higher up in the alphabet. Political candidates are more likely to win if they have early alphabet names rather than late names. There is even something called alphabet fatigue, which is a phenomenon where a dictionary or encyclopedia team becomes less and less thorough as they move through the letters. The first alphabetized edition of encyclopedia Britannica had three volumes, each of roughly
长度相当，第一卷是A到B。当然，正如我们所知，有许多文化、语言和文明在没有字母表的情况下也过得非常好，它们对于其他的排序系统也毫无怨言。在中国15世纪的明代，历史上最大的综合性百科全书是按照一个著名的韵律方案编排的。它在六个世纪里一直是世界上最大的参考书，而且运行得非常好。而在21世纪，人们开始转向其他寻找和排序信息的方式。
equal length, volume 1, was a through b. And of course, as we know, there are plenty of cultures and languages and civilizations that have done perfectly nicely without Nelfbed, and they have no problem with other sorting systems. During the Ming Dynasty in the 15th century China, the largest general encyclopedia in history was organized according to a well-known rhyming scheme. It remained the world's largest reference book for six centuries, and it worked just fine. And in the 21st century, people have started turning to other ways of finding and sorting information.
尽管互联网的许多底层基础设施都依赖于它，但没有人会用字母顺序来搜索维基百科或决定下一步点击哪篇文章。我们不再使用按字母顺序排列的索引，而是拥有通往成千上万个不同方向的超链接。字母顺序可能在无人注意时取得了胜利，但现在，它正同样悄无声息地变得过时。因此我们可能会发现，字母顺序只是一个阶段，一个八世纪的阶段，但它也可能只是一个阶段。我们有这个故事的代号吗？有的。稍后继续。所以我们又和丹尼尔·西摩在一起了。嘿，丹。嘿，罗曼。在我放你走之前，我听说你还有一件事想跟我们分享，关于字母顺序的。
Even as much of the internet's underlying infrastructure depends on it, no one uses alphabetical order to search through Wikipedia or to decide which article to click on next. Instead of indexes organized alphabetically, we have hyperlinks leading in a thousand different directions. Avertical order may have won when no one was looking, but now, just as quietly, it's being rendered obsolete. So we may discover that alphabetical order is a phase, an eighth century phase, but it might be a phase. Do we have a code for this story? Yes we do. After this. So we're here again with Daniel Simo. Hey, Dan. Hey, Roman. Before I let you go, I heard you have one more thing that you wanted to share with us regarding alphabetical order.
是的，确实有。我想把它留到彩蛋环节来说，因为你知道，作为一名记者，我最喜欢的事情之一就是当我采访的某个人真的极度痛恨他们的研究对象时。结果证明，朱迪丝·弗兰德斯是真的、真的很讨厌某个人。我在采访快结束、也就是快收尾时发现了这一点，当时我问了标准的那种收尾问题，我只想放一小段那时的录音给你听。还有什么我们没触及到、你觉得有必要提一下的吗？没有了，唯一的疑问是你是否希望我做这个，仅仅因为你说你希望有一些具有人物特色、生动的事物。
Yeah, I do. And I wanted to save it for the code up because, you know, as a reporter, one of the things I love the most is when someone I'm interviewing really hates one of their subjects. And it turns out that Judith Flann does really, really hates someone. And I found this out towards the end of the interview when I was wrapping things up and I asked my standard kind of wrap up question and I just want to play you some of that tape. Do there is anything that we haven't touched on that you think would be important to mention? There isn't the only thing I wonder if you want me to do just because you said you wanted a couple of sort of character driven things.
是的，是的。就是那个可怕的麦尔维尔·杜威（Melvil Dewey）。听到这儿你会想：哦，是的，请务必谈谈那个可怕的麦尔维尔·杜威吧。没错。是的，请务必讲讲。我是说，你知道，杜威在字母顺序方面没什么意思，除了他不用它。
Yeah, yeah. It is the hideous Melville, Joey. At which point you're like, oh, yes, please talk about the hideous Melville, do you? Exactly. Yes, please. Yeah. I mean, you know, Joey is not interesting in terms of alphabetical order, except he didn't use it.
但他实在是太讨厌了！我是说，除此之外，那个笨蛋居然把自己的名字拼成……我是说，除此之外，那个笨蛋居然把自己的名字拼成 M-E-L-V-I-L。我是说，真的吗？我没想到自己还能更喜欢朱迪丝·弗兰德斯，但我真的很享受她表现出的对杜威的这种极端嫌弃。对吧？所以，麦尔维尔·杜威，对于那些不知道的人来说，他是杜威十进制分类法（Dewey Decimal System）的发明者，或者官方称为杜威十进制分类法（DDC），这是一种图书馆的排序方法，在美国和当今的许多图书馆中依然非常普遍。
But he was so ghastly. I mean, apart from anything else, the moron spelled his name, but he was so ghastly. I mean, apart from anything else, the moron spelled his name, M-E-L-V-I-L. I mean, really? I didn't think I could love due to flander's anymore, but I really enjoy how much C-seems to not enjoy Melville. Do we? Yeah. And so Melville, do we, for those who don't know, the inventor of the Dewey decimal system or officially the Dewey
所以，除了杜威拼写自己名字的那种让人反感的方式之外，她到底不喜欢他什么呢？嗯，她对他有几点意见。基本上，麦尔维尔·杜威于1851年出生于纽约州北部的一个小镇。他其实在很年轻的时候就改了自己名字的拼写，因为他是当时简化英语拼写运动的粉丝。有一段时间，他甚至把姓氏的拼写改成了 DUI。但没能坚持下去？没有，那个没坚持下来。显然，银行拒绝承认他的签名，所以……对，如果你不能兑现支票，那这个改动就坚持不下去了。没错。所以，
decimal classification or DDC, which is a sorting method for libraries that is still very common in the US and many libraries today. So apart from the objectionable way that due to things he spells his name, what doesn't she like about him? Well, she's got a few issues. So basically Melville Dewey was born in a small town in upstate New York in 1851. And he actually changed the spelling of his name when he was quite young because he was a fan of the movement at the time to simplify English spelling. For a while, he even changed the spelling of his last name to DUI. But didn't stick? No, that one didn't stick. Apparently, the bank refused to recognize his signature, so. Yeah, if you can't catch checks, then it doesn't stick. Exactly. So,
杜威（Dewey，拼写为 D-E-W-E-Y）毕业于马萨诸塞州的阿默斯特学院，朱迪丝·弗兰德斯说，不久之后他在那里被任命为图书管理员。所以他当时二十多岁，但被要求给那里的图书馆编目。很有可能，他对图书馆分类法知之甚少，于是他重新拾起了知识等级制的理念，这是基于更古老的古典自由艺术理念。需要指出的是，当时很多图书馆和现在一样，已经在某种程度上按主题进行了分类。所以所有的微积分书都会在一个地方，所有的美国历史书会在另一个地方。但杜威采纳了这个基本理念，然后可以说是权力熏心，
DUI, D-E-W-E-Y, graduated from Amherst College in Massachusetts, and Judith Flandes says that soon after he was made a librarian there. So he's still in his twenties, but he was asked to catalog its library. The odds are pretty good. He didn't know much about library classification, so he returned to the idea of a hierarchy of knowledge, which is based on the older classical liberal arts idea. And it's important to point out that a lot of libraries back then, just like now, were already organized by subject, at least on some level. So all the calculus books would be in one place and all the American history books would be in another. But do he took the basic idea and kind of when, let's say mad with power,
他真的像柯勒律治一样坚信，所有的知识都以这种优雅的等级体系相互联系。所以在他的新系统中，一旦你到了某个主题领域，它就会被细分为更小的主题领域，而这些主题领域本身又会被细分为更小的主题领域，以此类推，没完没了。所以它成了层层叠叠的无限细分主题。是的。这就是他以自己名字命名的杜威十进制分类法。之所以里面有“十进制”这个词，是因为所有这些
he really believed just like Coleridge, that all knowledge was connected in this elegant hierarchy. So in his new system, once you got to the subject area, it would just be divided into smaller subject areas, which themselves would be divided into yet smaller subject areas and so on and so on. So it becomes subjects all the way down. Yeah. And this was his eponymous dewey decimal system, dewey decimal classification. And the reason it has the word decimal in there is because all of these
主题都被分配了数字。例如，500大类是自然科学，590大类是动物学，595是其他无脊椎动物，595.7是昆虫，如果你顺着往下找，最终就会找到蝴蝶。嗯，好吧，这说得通。好的。到目前为止，这似乎并不是什么真正的问题。是的，是的，完全如此。这完全不是一个坏主意。而且或许更重要的是，在当时，它为组织书籍提供了一种现成的、开箱即用的解决方案。
subjects were assigned numbers. So, for example, the 500s are natural sciences, 590s zoology, 595 is other invertebrates, 595.7s, the insight, and eventually you get to butterflies if you follow along. Yeah, well, that makes sense. Okay. It doesn't seem like this is a real problem so far. Yeah, yeah, exactly. It wasn't totally a bad idea. And perhaps more importantly, at that time, it offered this kind of ready-made, off-the-rack solution for organizing books.
它最终在19世纪下半叶被许多这样的机构所采用。所以即使它并不完美，但由于它被广泛使用，你可以去这个国家的任何一家图书馆，并且知道在哪里可以找到东西。这大概是它最大的优势。绝对的。基本上就是它的无处不在。但朱迪丝·弗兰德斯指出，它有几个大问题。
And it ended up getting picked up by a lot of these institutions throughout the second half of the 19th century. So even if it's not perfect, it's used so widely that you could go to any library in the country and know where to find things. And that's probably its biggest advantage. Definitely. It's ubiquity basically. But Judith Flinders points out that it had a few big problems.
它的好处是，如果你想了解你研究的主题，它的编号是什么，你走到书架前，所有的书都在那儿。所以它能帮助你更笼统地了解一个主题。它做不到的是帮你找到一本特定的书。而这正是症结所在。所以如果你在找一本特定的书，而你又不知道该把它归入哪个分类（你知道的，就像那种 0.7.6.3 的方式），你知道，它可能是按等级排列的，可能是符合逻辑的，但在人类世界里，把每一本书放在什么地方，其实并不是那么直观。不，它真的一点都不直观。
The benefit is, if you want to find out about the subject you work at, which its number is, you go to the shelves and there are all the books. So it helps you find out about a subject more generally. What it doesn't do is help you find a specific book. And this is sort of the crux. So if you're looking for a specific book, and you don't know where to classify it, you know, like in the 0.7.6.3 way, you know, it may be hierarchical, it may be logical, but it's not really all that intuitive of where you place every book in the human world. No, it's not.
所以，杜威别无选择，只能将他的系统与卡片目录结合起来，卡片目录会告诉你去哪里找这本书。你猜杜威十进制分类法的卡片目录用的是什么排序方法？我不用猜，肯定是字母顺序。没错，还是我们的老朋友。所以到头来，尽管你多么想把世界编排进这些由100个数字组成的区块中，并不断地细分、细分、再细分。当你到底层时，你还是得回到字母顺序上来。
So, do we have no choice but to pair his system with a card catalog, which would tell you where to find the book? And do you want to guess what sorting method to do a decimal system card catalog uses? I don't need to guess, it's alphabetical order. Yep, our old friend. So in the end, you know, as much as you want to order the world into these blocks of 100 numbers and subdivided and subdivided and subdivided. When you get to the bottom, you have to get to alphabetical order.
它某种程度上是这一切的基础。是的，是的。尽管应该指出的是，杜威成功地把这一点转化为了自己的优势。因为杜威做的事情是，推动他在1876年共同创立的美国图书馆协会（ALA）将索引卡片的尺寸标准化，然后使用他自己创建的一家名为“图书馆局”（Library Bureau）的公司来提供管理这些卡片目录所需的所有耗材。
It sort of underlies everything. Yeah, yeah. Although it should be pointed out that, do he manage to turn this to his advantage? Because what do he did was to push the American Library Association, which he had co-founded in 1876, to standardize that index card size and to then use a company he created called the Library Bureau to provide all the supplies needed
哇。这非常具有进取精神，而且也有点狡猾。我是说，这就是朱迪丝讨厌他的原因吗？比如说，因为这种从图书馆系统中牟利的方式？不，不是的。
to manage those card catalogs? Whoa. That's very enterprising and a little bit sneaky. I mean, is this the reason why Judith hates him? Like, because of this, you know, way of profiting from the library system. No, it's
相反，事实证明，卡片目录其实是杜威系统中最小的问题。因为当你开始深入研究它的分类系统时，你很快就会意识到，问题主要在于杜威本人以及他是如何看待世界的。所有的排序系统都有偏见。杜威的偏见比大多数系统都要多，而在现代世界里，这一点尤其令人头疼。它完全是以盎格鲁-撒克逊为中心的。它几乎可以说是荒谬地以基督教为中心的。因此，基督教被赋予了介于200到
not. Instead, it turns out that the card catalog is the least of the Dewey systems problems. Because when you start digging into its classification system, you soon realize that the problem was mostly duey himself and how he saw the world. All sorting systems have biases. Dewey's has more biases than most, and in the modern world it is particularly troublesome. particularly troublesome. It is entirely Anglo-centric. It is almost comically Christian-centric. So Christianity was given all the numbers between 200 and
289之间的所有数字，而伊斯兰教只被赋予了一个单一的数字：297。哦，女性最初被非常整洁地归类在“礼仪”的旁边。气急败坏？我吗？不，一点也不。但除了他创造的系统之外，还有杜威这个人本身。杜威本人是一个令人发指的糟糕透顶的人。我带着完全的偏见说这句话。他创立了美国图书馆协会，但当四名女性投诉他在两周内对她们进行性骚扰时，他被迫辞职。他是反犹太主义者，他是种族主义者，即使在那个充满反犹和种族主义的年代里。他也被认为相当可怕，所以他还被要求辞去
289 whereas Islam is given only a single number 297. Oh and women are originally categorized very neatly next to etiquette. Bitter? Me? No, not at all. But beyond the system that he created, there was just do-e the man. Do-e himself was a mind-blowingly awful person. I say this with complete prejudice. He founded the American Library Association, but was forced to step down when four women complained that he had assaulted them in a two-week period. He was anti-Semitic, he was racist, even in anti-Semitic and racist days. He was considered to be pretty horrible, so he was also asked to stand down from his
纽约州立图书馆管理员的职务，原因是他推行基督教白人至上的政策。你可以想象，在那个时代，他一定做了极其过分的事，才会沦落到那个地步。哇，我隐约觉得杜威是个问题人物，但我完全不知道他居然这么糟糕。是的，是的，他绝对是。正是因为这些无可否认的恶劣行径，美国图书馆协会最近决定将他的名字从他们的高层领导荣誉奖项中移除。这个奖项以前叫“麦尔维尔·杜威奖章”，但在2020年，它被改名为“ALA卓越奖章”。
position as librarian for New York State for his Christian white-only policies. And if you can imagine in those times it must have taken an awful lot for him to get to that stage. Wow, it had some vague notion that Dui was a problem, but I had no idea just how awful he really was. Yeah, yeah, he definitely was. And because of all this undeniable awfulness, the American Library Association recently decided to take his name off their top leadership honor. It used to be called the Melville-Duey Medal, but in 2020 it was changed to the ALA Medal
但问题是，即使杜威本人没有被好生铭记，他的系统依然生机勃勃。尽管事实上它现在已经不太好用了，但当然，撤销整个图书馆并重新分类变得非常困难，所以人们总体上还是没有这么做。因此，人们开发了其他的排序方法，国会图书馆也有它自己的系统。但根据最近的估计，135个国家中大约有20万家图书馆仍然在使用杜威十进制分类法。哇。所以杜威掌控了他们，但世界很早就接受了他们，因此无论好坏，我们现在只能被困在杜威的等级体系里了。确实如此。谢谢你，丹。谢谢你，罗曼。本周的“99%无形”由丹尼尔·西摩制作，乔·罗斯伯格剪辑，阿米达·加纳特拉进行混音和技术制作，音乐由声音总监肖恩·里豪制作。唯一的音乐人就是我们能
of excellence. But the thing is, even if Jewie himself isn't well remembered, his system is still going strong. Despite the fact that it just doesn't work very well anymore, but of course, undoing an entire library and recategorizing becomes very difficult so people on the whole don't. So other sorting methods have been developed, and the Library of Congress has its own system. But according to recent estimates, roughly 200,000 libraries in 135 countries still use the Dewey Decimal classification. Wow. So Dewey dictates them, but the world embraced them early
制作的那些，库尔特·科尔斯特德担任数字总监。团队的其他成员包括维维安·勒、拉杰玛·多恩、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、埃mett·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯·巴鲁贝、索菲亚·克拉茨克，以及我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是 Stitcher 和 SiriusXM 播客家族的一部分。现在总部位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区北部六个街区的潘多拉大厦。你可以在 Facebook 上找到本节目并参与有关节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我（@Roman Mars），或@本节目（@99PIOrg）。在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上也可以找到。你可以在 99PI.org 上找到我喜爱的 Stitcher 节目的链接，以及
and then therefore we're just gonna stuck with Dewey's hierarchy for better or worse. Very much so. Thank you Dan. Thanks, Norman. 99% of visible was produced this week by Daniel Seemo, edited by Joe Rosenberg, mixed in tech production by Amida Ganatra, music by a director of Sound Swan Rihau. The only hall is ours that could
99PI 过去每一集的链接。这里有一个事实，直到我在三十多岁有了孩子之前我都不知道。说真的，这让我大开眼界。Stitcher，Sirius XM。本集还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。
produce her, Kurt Colestead is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Vivian Le, Lajma Don, Christopher Johnson, Emmett Fitzgerald, Chris Baroube, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are part of the Stitcher and Serious XM podcast family. Now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars on the show at 9-9-PI-O work. On Instagram and read it too. You can find links to Stitcher shows I love, as well as
制作人，Kurt Colestead是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括Vivian Le、Lajma Don、Christopher Johnson、Emmett Fitzgerald、Chris Baroube、Sophia Klatsker，以及我Roman Mars。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客大家庭的一部分。总部现在位于奥克兰美丽的住宅区上城潘多拉大厦以北六个街区。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上@我Roman Mars或节目@99PI。也可以在Instagram和Reddit上找到。你可以找到我喜欢的Stitcher节目的链接，以及
every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. Here's the fact I didn't know until I had kids in my thirties. Seriously, it blew my mind. Stitcher, serious exam. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
99PI每一期过去的节目，网址是99PI.org。这是我直到三十岁有了孩子才知道的一个事实。说真的，这让我大开眼界。Stitcher，SiriusXM。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。